let's talk about this great I stay home
for campaign that you're doing which has
really caught on tell us how that got
started you know it became pretty clear
to me pretty quickly that the one thing
that the virus really really didn't like
at this point was social distancing and
and being you know us isolating
ourselves so we came up with this
hashtag I stay home for and it was a
very simple idea which was just I've
just held up a poster and said I stay
home for kyra sedgwick because the idea
is that you know you can feel okay but
you can go out and somebody can get sick
and somebody else can get sick and that
person could be connected and connected
and connected to somebody that you
really care about you know whether
someone's [ __ ] or grandmother or
child or whatever and you know this is a
frustrating situation because we we want
to have something that we can do and
there are a lot of people who are doing
heroic work who can't stay home medical
workers and and and first responders and
even you know the mailman and them and
the people that are delivering food etc
etc but for those of us that they can't
stay home this seemed like a pretty
simple thing that we could try to do and
the other piece of it is that the reason
that I was the sort of like became the
kind of face of it initially is just
because of the six degrees of Kevin
Bacon because I've always felt that you
need to take me out of the game like if
you take if the game has nothing to do
with me which it really doesn't it's
really the idea that we are connected
and the coronavirus is kind of a
terrifying example of that yeah but on
the other hand we see now that the
connections between people are really
really very powerful and and we're all
really hungry for that I don't know
about you but you know I'm spending time
soomi with my family
reaching out to people that haven't
spoken to for a really long time
checking in checking in checking in
because even though we're isolated we're
hungry for
connections yeah well what I'm doing is
Ivan I'm having my manager call
everybody and I'm told they're all doing
really well but no I know what you mean
I'm I'm doing the exact same thing I
think we're all doing that now and I
wanted to throw in my support for your
campaign so I think it's a really cool
idea what I'm supposed to do is write
out hashtag I stay home for my first
draft was also kyra sedgwick she's
already been done I know I understood
that you have some connection with her
that I see I guess is more important
than mine I don't personally get it I
just want to say my parents I stay home
from my parents because I you know my
parents are up there and that's who I
think about in this time in this crisis
I'm staying home and I want to encourage
other people to stay home because I want
to keep people of that generation safe
because you're the most vulnerable so to
me that is paying for their car they
they're doing well so far
and they really love that I'm staying
away from them that's their favorite
part because they have a lot of kids and
I was never the favorite so let me make
sure I mentioned that season one of city
on a hill is available on Showtime on
demand and there's never been a better
time to catch up on these great shows
that are out there on streaming it is a
golden age of streaming city on a hill
is terrific
so check it out now while you're sitting
at home waiting for your post mates
delivery and join in on the hashtag I
stay home for campaign on social media
and you can learn more about Kevin's
philanthropic work at six degrees dot
org it's organization that's doing a lot
of good Kevin thank you very much for
doing this but it is so much for having
me and you know hopefully next time we
see each other it won't be unzip I'm
told I
look better and zoom this might be the
way you prefer to talk to me next time
thank you for being here Kevin and take
care of yourself and my best to Kira
back at you man